hey everyone I'm here with David grand
author of pillars of the flower moon New
York Times best seller and boy is this
interesting this is is because it's
actually multiple tales in one it's a
murder mystery a true crime murder
mystery about the Osage Nation in
Oklahoma Native Americans and suddenly a
number of them are being killed two
dozen of them are being killed tell us a
little bit more about yes about 2,000 or
so of them in northeast Oklahoma have
become the wealthiest people per capita
in the world because of oil under their
land was said at the time whereas one
American might own a car each Osage own
11 of them um in 1923 those two thousand
or so Osage received what would be worth
today more than four hundred million
dollars and then they began to die under
very mysterious and sinister
circumstances right about one woman
Molly Burkhardt who watches she has a
younger sister was blown up in her house
and one by one the Osage are being
killed through the shooting poisoning
finding more than two dozen and that's
when eventually and that is sort of the
second tale here but I should say with
the Osage Indians what's sort of
fascinating about their journey is I
mean it's part of American history the
mistreatment of Native Americans here
they are pushed off of their land and
pushed and pushed and pushed and then
they sort of just decide you know what
we're gonna settle on this rock there's
nothing there you can't grow anything
and they think we will settle here
because the white man won't come at
birth here they won't want what's here
and what ends up being there is a whole
lot of oil which is what makes them very
very rich
right they want to control much of the
central part of the country all the way
from the edge of Kansas to the edge of
the Rockies I'm in 1803 Thomas Jefferson
referred to them as the great nation and
then slowly they were driven off their
land they were forced to steal their
land and then in the 1870s they were
driven off again off their land in
Kansas and that's when the Osage chief
stood up in their store a record of what
he said and he said our people should
move to this land was then Indian
Territory would later become part of
Oklahoma because the land is rocky its
infertile Oh
aw Marlon they would actually hold these
auctions for leases under this elm tree
for land so that they could drill on and
these leases would sell for anywhere
between as much as two million dollars
and the elm tree became known as the
million dollar round then you mentioned
you know the the Osage became incredibly
wealthy and much to the despair chagrin
of some so wealthy that they were able
to even higher white sermon yes all the
way back to the original content right
and the brutal first contact and really
the original sin from which the country
was born and not only did it leaving
your nation have millions in your trust
and you had a white person telling you
whether you could get this toothpaste at
the corner store or this car and now not
only was this system deeply racist I
mean it was literally based on the
quantum Osage blood whether you had a
a guardian it also led to an enormous
criminal enterprises many Guardians
swindled millions and millions so there
you have the backdrop and then Story
number two is what I felt was sort of
the coming-of-age of the FBI that there
in terms of federal law enforcement it
was theirs
there weren't really wasn't anything the
country had rejected the concept of
federal law enforcement for years right
I don't want the government coming in
and telling me what to do see how this
would ragtag law enforcement and so at
this point under of all people Hoover
the FBI is becoming so many have been
killed many law enforcement in tried to
catch the killers those be some of them
were killed and also there was deep
widespread corruption among law
enforcement back then locally it was a
still a very lawless country if you were
powerful you could tip the scales of
justice resolution mattering the country
agents were still not allowed to make
arrests they acted to get local
authorities to do it they weren't
authorized to carry guns and so this
disappeared when the Bureau is trying to
modernize they've got new technology
like fingerprinting and so what's
amazing is they bring in but they were
in this transitional period they
eventually bring in which is the part of
the second story this field agent a guy
named Tom White who came of age at a
time when law was kind of practiced up
by the smoking barrel of a gun yeah and
now he shows up in Washington you know
wearing his to having to use
fingerprints has to file paperwork which
he can't stand he's becoming part of a
larger bureaucratic organization um and
he's asked to take over the case down
the bureau up until that point it really
messed up
and they get even got an outlaw out of
jail hope to use him as an informant and
City robbed the bank and killed the
police officer Joe Hoover who was new in
his job he was only 29 he's worried
about the scandal and so he turns the
white to hopefully save his and white
put together this undercover team and he
I I can't even believe that this guy
existed the FBI agent white because he's
almost perfect like you said he he sort
of comes up in a law-and-order type of
family that used to sort of a Wild West
environment but he's interested in this
more professional more systematic
version of law enforcement and crime
investigation
yes and I thought most interestingly not
part of the undercover team and they're
no statistic but I think it's fair to
say that he was the only American Indian
in Hoover's Bureau at the time given her
Hoover's prejudice and then going
undercover and they try to follow the
money because it's you think you know it
and then it just becomes so much bigger
than that but this area of Oklahoma is
just Attica bro there's almost no law I
mean every witness that they try to have
run down has been killed or is already
in jail for something else
there was a man who won one lawyers
thrown off a speeding train there's a
man who goes to Washington DC this was
before 1923 hoping to get the feds that
federal authorities to investigate he
checks into a boarding house he's
carrying a Bible and a pistol he
receives the message from a colleague
and associate no Holman says be careful
he checks out he leaves the morning
house that evening he is abducted at
some time at some point a sock is placed
over his bed he has found the next day
in a Cobra he was beaten to death and
stabbed more than 20 times right and
then that the Washington Post had a
headline that said conspiracy to kill
the rich oh right um when I was reading
this I thought how on earth did you do
the research because it's clear that you
know the osage are kind of seen as sort
of Half Men they're not full sort of
full citizens in a way I thought there
couldn't be a lot of documentation about
their movements and how one was just it
was someone who was born in a wigwam in
the 1880s which is essentially you know
speaking of stage traditions within a
few years the US government forces her
to go to a boarding school cross as far
as she's ever been from her home she has
to remove her postage blanket she's no
longer allowed to speak her language
yes after the white man's tongue and
then within a few decades because oil
money she's married to white settlers
she's living in a mansion she speaks
English she straddles not only two
centuries but two civilization was
[Music]
negated based on the records all troops
by I'm limited by what I can find
finally so I went through I track down
who stage descent is one of the most
powerful experiences I had was tracking
down the descendants of the killers
another victim many of them live in the
same neighborhoods today that's still
part of the story of American why this
is important and one of the people I
tracked down was Molly's granddaughter a
lovely woman named Martha Burkhardt and
she gave me great insight into Molly
into the family she took me out the
graveyard were so many of her buried no
look
you start to realize that this was a
Holocaust in many ways and speaking to
Margie yeah but this would have because
the whole idea was to the whole idea was
to steal the wealth underneath the
ground the land rights right from from
the Osage this would have changed the
trajectory of these two families you
know when you talk about sort of old
money old this is about taking away that
money um but they're these relatives are
still living among with each other I
mean do they get along I did they I
toured the end of the book and one of
the things he told me is that you know
we have descendants just living down the
street he's dead in some cases they
don't know you know what their ancestors
did or they don't want to know and I
thought with great understanding and
pretty initiative but we don't hold them
responsible for the blood of their
forebearers remarkable and I get an
event which is really interesting I had
there were descendents of many of the
victims were there many and there was
the descendant of one of the masterminds
one of the killer's was and her and
Margie actually came over to certain
point and embraced and so there again
you see this you're still playing out
today how could something like this and
I know it was covered in the media but I
never heard of this story before
yearbook how did something like this go
unnoticed yeah I mean I think sadly you
know hardly why so many of the murder
victims were ignored it was because they
were Native Americans many of these
cases went unsolved and one of the
really
in the language beyond this have a name
that's named after a moon and the month
of May is known as the little flower
killing moon because only beautiful
flowers spread across Prairie the
beautiful duet it looks almost like
confetti and then the larger plants come
and steal their water and steal their
light and those beautiful flowers die
out and the first murder disappearance
of Molly's sister in a brown book or not
um your last book of velocity you know
it's an interesting Erebus it's about
really the transformation in the country
and the lost in easy about this explorer
it's really the beginning of the end of
that kind of old exploration these
people kind of ventured in he ventured
into the Amazon that disappeared these
people would venture into unknown places
with a machete and a compass and almost
the divine sense of purpose that arrow
was ending yeah and all the characters
are quite fascinating they are rough
around the edges sort of venturing into
becoming polished yeah it like I said
before it's almost hard to believe that
they're real life people I mean as you
were reading about them were you
starting to it seems like forever the
FBI agent Tom White isn't you personally
really like I did I mean you know it's
funny but as a reporter you are always
[Music]
and there's a this is a real you
settings wonderful to spend time with
them are they alive Lily are you
spending you know I spent five almost
five years working on this book so yes
they come you really come to spend time
with them with their diaries their
letters their photographs and over the
years they kind of ah ah you spend more
time with them than I did with all my
you know my friend other than my wife
and children I spend more time with them
than anybody else in humanity um but I
suppose that is that is what this
country is made of right I mean it's
hard to sort of carve out a brand-new
country out of the wilderness but what
era what
I think that is a great point David I
think that one of the things I love
about this is the fact that it is Oracle
and so you're sort of getting your
vegetables wrapped in a coating of
mystery and murder according candy but
your vegetables are underneath it's a
fantastic book killers of the flower
moon David Graham thank you